this is the flaming hot doritos logos
pizza this is inspired by taco bells
flamin hot doritos locos taco
i'm gonna be honest bro i hate the way
it looks yeah i lied to you
looks horrendous
hey everybody it's nicole russell from
last dragon pizza
welcome to peace awards on first week
feast week after week i've been battling
some insanely talented chefs
on my quest to become the world's next
master pizza maker
but today we're pushing the limits of
what a pizza can be
by creating the ultimate mashup prize i
can't think of anyone better for this
event
than the master of fast food mashups
mythical chef
josh shearer
hey what's up everybody my name is
mythical chef josh i'm from mythical
kitchen super excited to be battling
nicole today she is a
master pizzaiola i've been watching her
on this show but i think i'm the wild
card to come in
and take her down i started the snack
talking real early alright so today i am
making a pizza inspired by the flamin
hot doritos logos taco the greatest
culinary innovation
from our time from taco bell i grew up
eating taco bell like at least twice a
week
i'm gonna use their culinary innovation
to inspire
my own today i'm going to be preparing a
jamaican beef patty with cheese inspired
pizza
i was born here but my parents are
jamaican and growing up in new york city
i've always marveled at seeing the beef
patty with cheese in italian pizzerias
today's judges are chef jay lee and
complex's own speedy mormon
these guys are true new yorkers and they
really know their food so i'm feeling
pretty good about my chances
look nicole's absolutely incredible we
are on her home turf today but me
i got that wild card factor i'm like
that rugby player that shows up to the
nfl like
oh it might let's play some footy that's
the energy that i'm coming in does that
make sense to anybody it made sense to
me
josh i'm so excited that you're here you
have a red dough so i need to know
what are you making today i'm making the
flamin hot doritos locos pizza this is
inspired by the taco bell item the
flamin hot doritos logos taco they
literally made a taco shell
out of flamin hot doritos so i have made
a pizza dough out of flamin hot doritos
oh
my goodness i have a confession to make
i've never had taco bell don't tell me
that anymore nicole don't what
you got i've always meant to get taco
bell i just never
got taco bell in my life i used to eat
taco bell at least twice a week when i
was in elementary school my parents
didn't really cook
and so i was a total latchkey kid i
would get my like you know five dollars
allowance every week and i would stop by
taco bell on my way home from school it
was like the most
explosive flavor i'd ever had up to that
point and it was something like really
inspired my sort of culinary creativity
and my journey
i'm glad that my first experience is
gonna be with you
thank you thank you so much i hope i do
talk about justice i'm sure you will it
looks great already
all right so we stretched the dough out
we got it like a nice almost like a
personal pan pizza size i don't want to
get
big on it thank you so much thank you so
much now we're going to sauce taco bell
beef is something that i'm i'm
passionate about i guess
it's basically a tex-mex spiced
bolognese you got like the cumin in
there you got a lot of black pepper
so i'm gonna take that and i'm gonna dot
some sharp cheddar cheese around it all
right so i'm throwing this in the oven
right now we got this set to broil we're
gonna drop it down to 500 it's just to
heat the stones we're going to par bake
it for like five minutes pull it
crust it garnish it yeah
oh that is looking absolutely perfect
right there
i'm just gonna take some iceberg lettuce
and i'm just gonna dot that around i
want that fresh crunch on there and then
i'm gonna take
some of these roma tomatoes so this is
just a little bit of chipotle habanero
crema oh we got arizona gunslinger
really fantastic hot sauce oh i love
this combination
there's the flamin hot doritos locos
pizza now i need my slice
this is the best part of the show
oh no this is amazing oh man
i know i do this every episode but this
is really good
the crust on the outside is really
crunchy but i like that the inside is
kind of soft and the bottom
is also a little crunchy and crispy
you're gonna go to taco bell and you're
gonna understand how much this tastes
like taco bell oh my goodness this is so
good you're getting all that textural
contrast it's a taco
pizza at the end of the day right you're
getting the cold from the lettuce that
little bit like the creamy habanero
crema on there
yeah it's good it's gonna be good it's
silly it's really good
oh it's so hot oh yes
[Laughter]
that'll cool you down
[Music]
all right josh your pizza was great it
blew my mind
but are you ready for jamaican beef
patty with cheese pizza
i have never been more ready i'm already
loving what's going on in your
stationery this looks incredible
well this is our dough the way that i uh
prepare this dough
is similar to like a buss-up shop you
ever heard of a bus-stop shop
i know bus up [ __ ] i know what's up shot
roti you know they take it and they cut
it and they roll it out and then they
put the butter in
tell me about the new york pizzerias
that have the beef patty eggs i'm west
coast i'm la it's a staple in new york
you know like you come to new york you
go to outer bars especially
you get a slice and you get a beef patty
with cheese and they open it up for you
they slice it open and they put the
mozzarella all over it
as a person growing up of jamaican
heritage
it was like unheard of unheard of to cut
a beef patty open
but now when you go to jamaica guess
what you get
beef patty with cheese if it wasn't for
the beef patty i don't think i would
have been introduced to pizza i saw the
beef patty in the window
and it made me feel welcome i want to
say pick up yourself
all the jamaican mustards up there what
i'm representing for you
[Music]
all right so it's been par baking for
five minutes i'm gonna pull it out and
then i'm gonna top it with some meat
so what i did was i took some chopped
onions and scallions
and then i put the beef sauteed it down
and then i add the allspice
the little oyster sauce thyme and the
scotch bonnet
what we're gonna do is we're gonna take
some beef and then we're gonna top it
with the mozzarella
so i'm ready to put this bad boy in the
oven jump in here
all right
i think it's ready my favorite thing
about this show is y'all like the pizza
like
straight out the oven so the bottom has
that like flake but it's still a pizza
yeah wow let's see if it folds up a
little crunch
what you know about that though
let's go one two three cheers hey look
i'm all right
the spicing on the beef is incredible
the heat from the scotch bonnet stupid
good but like
the thing to me that that puts this over
the top is the freaking texture i've
never had anything like it
yeah you know i kind of wanted to make
it feel like a beef patty but it has to
be a pizza
josh your pizza was amazing it was super
inventive but it's only one thing left
to do
go to the judges table we've got
complexes speedy mormon
we've got chef j lee so let's see what
they think
[Music]
speedy jay thank you so much for being
here thank you so much
for having us i'm excited to be here i'm
glad to be here too josh
you're up first this is the flamin hot
doritos logos pizza this is inspired by
taco bell's flamin hot doritos locos
taco
we have a flamin hot powder infused
crust there's a taco bell spiced
bolognese under there
a little bit of sharp cheddar chipotle
habanero crema and then that iceberg
lettuce and tomato
i'm gonna be honest bro i hate the way
it looks
looks horrendous i don't like the things
i do sometimes either i'm going to
give it a go one to ten how spicy are we
talking we're rocking like what like a
7.2
let's see what's up with it
[Music]
speedy's got that new york judgment in
his eyes both of them are serious
i think you nailed the taco bell pizza
it tastes like taco bell 100 it took me
back
to my high school days when i rolled my
bike right up to taco bell
ordered tacos put matte sauce on and
just hey that's what it tastes like to
me
it looks like a pizza it eats like a
pizza i think you did a good job
i'm very happy with what i'm tasting
thank you chef some constructive
criticism
for me i think the dough was a little
too thick um around the crust and
underneath the pizza
i don't think there was enough integrity
it didn't hold its structure
taco bell taco breaks after two bites so
it's trying to give you the authentic
experience
he's talking about integrity it's
getting personal
i'm not even gonna lie to you this is
fire yes
this is very good it's crazy like it's
very good i'm not going to come at your
integrity
or the integrity of the pizza but i
think it's great i love it i'm not a
spicy guy
but it's not too spicy it's like just
right for me five stars my friend
i'm ready to eat more this is
my version of a jamaican beef patty with
cheese
but it's a pizza so it's inspired by
classic
new york outer borough pizzerias that
will put the beef patty in the window
enjoy oh my god it's already it's gonna
change my life
but look at the integrity on that don't
see how i use the word integrity
it's holding right the crush really does
look like a patty though that's crazy
wow
that's so [ __ ] good oh my god
you nailed it this tastes like a beef
patty look at the crust
look at the color i think the
seasoning's on point very intentional
every little detail was really thought
out like really really well
i mean if i didn't know who you are and
i taste this pizza
i would say whoever made this pizza
really grew up eating this food
because you can just taste it amazing
thank you so much
it's fire you see how we pulled it and
that cheese just stretched out like
like the pizza commercials when they use
glue and all that but it's real
cheese the beef is seasoned so well
i feel like my grandmother seasoned this
meat but you
made it so much flavor with every bite
so much flavor
so much flavor this is so much i love it
we both can't take it anymore you guys
have to decide
who is the winner speedy jay
who's the winner it was a really tough
decision because both
variations really nailed uh the
inspiration but i'm gonna have to say
the winner is
[Music]
nicole oh my god okay one down jesus
both of y'all came to play i thought i
was coming here to
show a little bicep you enjoy some
people accomplish i did get the bicep
off
what these pies both
crazy one is a 10 and the other
is a 9.95
and i'm gonna choose the winner by just
taking a bite of it oh god
oh my god oh no
oh no
it's like like a beef patty but
different enough both amazing
but 10 and 9.95
[Music]
nicole this is a seven game series first
of four wins and nicole with this
beef patty inspired pizza you just
clinched you got your fourth win
what are you feeling right now how
honored are you to be sitting in front
of me
first of all i'm always honored for
anyone you know to help me better my
craft but at the end of the day
i also love having my guests and they're
so fantastic so it's always a win-win
for me
but i'm not gonna lie four oh my god
congratulations thank you so much i'm so
stoked that i won today
make sure you tune in next week for
peace awards
you